melina ist ein mädchen aus luckenwalde
hier ganz in der nähe und melina ist
spurlos verschwunden die polizei suche
nach ihr ein letztes foto zeigt das
mädchen im dunkeln auf einer parkbank
wir haben recherchiert was danach
geschehen ist und mit wem melina in
dieser nacht unterwegs war
unser nächster fall der ist ein ganz
persönlicher einmal spielt er hier ganz
in der nähe in luckenwalde was etwa so
eine stunde mit dem auto entfernt ist
genau dort da ist die 22 jährige melina
nach einer nacht mit freunden im park
spurlos verschwunden und dann hat ihr
papa sich bei uns gemeldet uns
kontaktiert achtung verhandlungen mit
einem großen wunsch bitte berichtet über
das verschwinden meiner tochter hat er
gesagt und bitte zeigt ihr foto willi
von der osten hat sich auf spurensuche
begeben
darf ich mich einmal vorstellen bin 21
jahre alt komme aus kasachstan wohne in
der nähe von berlin
seit dem 25
september ist melina spurlos
verschwunden doch inzwischen ermittelt
die staatsanwaltschaft potsdam in einem
tötungsdelikt gegen unbekannt es gibt
keinen hinweis darauf dass die junge
frau den mute park zu fuß mit einem taxi
oder einem öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
verlassen hat
zuletzt gesehen wird melina hier im jute
park in luckenwalde mit freunden feiert
und trinkt sie danach verliert sich ihre
spur ihr letztes lebenszeichen entsteht
hier auf dieser bank
um ein uhr morgens soll melina den park
verlassen und nach hause gegangen sein
ihre wohnung liegt nur zwei kilometer
von ute park entfernt doch dort kommt
sie nie an
freunde und familie starten einen
vermissten aufruf bei social media die
anteilnahme ist groß die polizei nimmt
die ermittlungen auf sucht den park nach
hinweisen ab auch ein kleiner bach die
nuthe wird abgetaucht ergebnislos das
mädchen bleibt verschwunden die
ermittler gehen zunächst jedoch nicht
von einem verbrechen aus milena sei von
zu hause abgehauen million us familie
stammt aus der ehemaligen sowjetunion
biela geht im brandenburgischen
luckenwalde zur schule machte eine
ausbildung zur bürokauffrau auf social
media zeigt sich die 22-jährige als
selbstbewusste junge frau gibt sich
freizügig und in partylaune eine
scheinwelt im wahren leben beschreibt
uns ihre arbeitskollegin die junge frau
ist eine völlig andere person
melina von zwei seiten immer der
schüchterne mädchen und einmal so wie
sie sich bei instagram präsentiert wo
man denkt es ist ein wirklich
selbstbewusste frau aber ich denke das
was äußerlich alles so erscheint das ist
halt mehr fassade war innerlich ist ein
wirklich sehr schüchternes mädchen sehr
sehr fleißiger
zuverlässig pünktlich
und jetzt kommen sie einfach nicht mehr
und das passt einfach nicht zu ihr
zuerst heißt es media sei auf dem weg
nach hause verschwunden
doch jetzt sagt die staatsanwaltschaft
ist gäbe keinerlei hinweise dass melina
den ute patt überhaupt verlassen hat was
ist in der nacht zum 25
september hier minute park in
luckenwalde mit der 22-jährigen melina
passiert
wir lernen eine freundin von melina über
instagram kennern kannst du uns erzählen
was an dem abend passiert ist sie hat
drei kumpels getroffen und mit ihnen
getrunken sie hat mir zuletzt um 0 uhr
11 ein video geschickt die drei jungs
haben getanzt sie saß auf der bank und
dann dann war sie gegen 1 uhr nachts auf
dem weg nach hause ein kumpel wollte sie
nach hause fahren aber sie wollte nicht
da er betrunken war was glaubst du ist
mit ihr passiert sie würde nicht einfach
abhauen sie wollte sich am nächsten tag
mit treffen hast du irgendein theorie
was passiert sein könnte
wahrscheinlich wurde sie entführt
wir treffen die jungs mit denen melina
in der nacht ihres verschwindens
zusammen war die letzten zeugen die
milena leben zehn einer der jungen
männer ist mit chinas ex freund nach
ihrer trennung finden sie wieder
zueinander
er sagt sie seien inzwischen gute
freunde filmen lassen wollen sie sich
nicht aber auch sie behaupten melina sei
um ein uhr morgens alleine nach hause
gegangen ein klarer widerspruch zu den
aussagen der staatsanwaltschaft von der
bank an der melina den abend verbringt
und sich von ihren freunden
verabschiedet haben soll ist ihr weg
leicht zu beobachten etwas verdächtiges
will aber niemand gesehen haben der fall
melina hinterlässt viele fragen wo ist
melina hinweise nimmt die
staatsanwaltschaft potsdam unter 0331
2017 0 entgegen
über diesen fall melina wollen wir jetzt
sprechen professor christian mazda auf
der bei uns im studio ist unser achtung
fahndung experte hallo professor für
kriminalistik und ehemaliger kripo
ermittler hermannsdorf der fall der hat
mich an einen anderen ungelösten
kriminalfälle inhalt an rebecca neusch
zwei junge frauen die sich beide im
internet so unglaublich selbstbewusst
geben und dann im wahren leben
eigentlich als schüchterne
zurückhaltende frauen beschrieben werden
geht es ähnlich ja also ich musste auch
unwillkürlich an rebecca neusch denken
obwohl sehr große unterschiede gibt vom
lebensalter 15 22 jahren und auch die
umstände der familie alle weiteren dinge
die das verschwinden waren ja etwas
anders gelagert als in diesem fall hier
mich hat auch erstaunt diese diskrepanz
zwischen der selbstinszenierung den
sozialen medien auf der einen seite und
auf der anderen seite so die
einschätzung von freunden familie und
anderen die sagt mich eigentlich ganz
stille menschen gar nicht so auffällig
gar nicht so lackiert zu auf hochglanz
gebracht das könnte natürlich auch ein
ermittlungs anhalt sein denn wenn in den
sozialen medien eine aufmerksamkeit
erregt wird eben für einen bestimmten
typ den man doch da stellt dieses
mädchen die dort sehr präsent sind dann
kann das sein dass da möglicherweise
auch täter darauf aufmerksam geworden
sind was diesen fall auch so besonders
macht es gibt sozusagen ein letztes foto
nämlich das foto von melina auf dieser
parkbank wenn sie dieses fotos sehen was
sagt ihnen das und wie würde man dann
als ermittler von diesem foto aus
weitergehen also dieses foto auf der
partnern das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
ausgangspunkt man kann sagen dass das
der ortes von dem die ermittlung
ausgehen neben den ermittlungen in der
familie in sozialen nahbereich freundes
bereich und alles was dazu gehört aber
dieser punkt ist offensichtlich der
bereich der für die ermittlungen zentral
wichtig ist für die spurensuche und
sicherung und auch was zeugen angeht und
auch was menschen angeht die ansonsten
eine wie auch immer geartete nähe gehabt
haben zum vermeintlichen tatzeitpunkt
jetzt haben wir gehört die
staatsanwaltschaft die sagt sehr klar
melina hat in der nacht diesen park
nicht mehr verlassen und dann gibt es
junge männer die mit ihr in diesem park
waren und die aber sagen doch doch die
ist gegangen was löst das bei ihnen als
ex kripo ermittler was also ersten
augenblick hat mich diese offenheit der
staatsanwaltschaft schon überrascht muss
ich sagen denn wenn man das im klartext
übersetzt dann heißt das eigentlich es
gab eine straftat es gab ein
tötungsdelikt und
dieses tötungsdelikt hat in dem park
stattgefunden und menschen die in dem
umfeld jetzt eine rolle spielen sind
entweder zeugen oder täter oder
tatbeteiligter also die
staatsanwaltschaft hat im prinzip mit
dieser aussage eine sehr klare statement
zu ihrer vermutung und ihr ermittlungs
linie hier vorgetragen so ihre erfahrung
wie oft kommt sowas ist so was eher
selten
es ist eher selten denn üblicherweise
hält sich die justiz die
staatsanwaltschaft sehr stark zurück es
ist ja auch eine frage wie die
ermittlungen weiter laufen sollen und
das ist sinnvoll mit den informationen
sparsam zu sein vielleicht ein verdacht
oder ein ermittlungs linie nicht gleich
öffentlich zu machen damit die
ermittlung zielführend zu ende geführt
werden können hier in dem fall muss
etwas vorliegen muss also tatsächlich
irgendetwas vorhandensein an beweisen an
indizien was die ermittlungsbehörden
sehr sehr sicher macht dass man das auch
in der öffentlichkeit zu präsentieren
kann hemmersdorf hin vielen dank für
diese einblicke und ihrer expertise
heute hier wieder bei uns wie immer sehr
gerne dankeschöns ja und wir haben es
gehört die polizei die ermittelt eben im
fall melina jetzt wegen des verdachts
eines tötungsdeliktes und die beamten
die brauchen ihre hilfe und fragen wem
ist in der nacht zum 25 september etwas
verdächtiges in der nähe des nuthe parks
oder im stadtgebiet in luckenwalde
aufgefallen wer hat melina irgendwo
gesehen wichtig ist sie trug in dieser
nacht eine schwarze lederhose und eine
weiße jacke hinweise an die
staatsanwaltschaft potsdam unter der
telefonnummer 0331 2 0 1 70
[Musik]